de l'est répit bienvenu pour tous les
responsables concernés alors que le plan
orsec est toujours maintenue dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence situation
difficile également dans le vaucluse
avec plusieurs centaines d'évacuations à
apt cavaillon bédarrides la population a
également été mise en état d' alerte à
vaison-la-romaine
reportage avec nos correspondants
patrice volet bernard connor la durance
tumultueuse large envahissante symbole
du vaucluse submergé de perthuis
jusqu'en l'avignon des kilomètres de
crue routes coupées diggs éclaté
terrains et maisons inondées l'eau a
pris toutes les libertés depuis hier
soir et ce dans tout le vaucluse dans
tout le sud-est alors il a fallu évacuer
ici un centre d'enfants près d'apt
mesures préventives là
des familles entières à sisteron juste
une valise vite fait à la main direction
un lit de fortune
alors il a fallu pomper pour atténuer
les dégâts des eaux l'ouvèze faisait
encore des siennes de vaison la romaine
à bédarrides
il ya la psychose s'il m'avait on
connais quand même ces phénomènes avait
la ride et swag sarivo connais d'autres
pourquoi pas reprendre des phénomènes
comme celui ci mais au fond ça va j'ai
l'impression qu'on brûle en comparaison
avec le jour pouvait commencer les
grandes manoeuvres par exemple soulager
les ponts encombré de troncs d'arbres ou
bien rechercher un enfant disparu jordi
12 ans emporté par les eaux à venasque
mais que de lassitude devant ces
débordements successifs car il faudra
encore reconstruire restera pas ne
pillez niveau dormi ans qu'on fait du
tout puis 5 heures du matin encore
attendre quelques guaino ce soir une
préoccupation majeure la crue du rhône
déjà avignon est assiégé la cote du
fleuve 7 mètres 30 au lieu de 3 mètres
50 en temps normal
de quoi inquiéter la camargue toute la
nuit